whether you like to be wrong and called
them gifs or be right and call them
gifts ripping photos are incredibly fun
maybe you even want to start making your
own and maybe you thought that would be
difficult it's not to new apps called
boomerang made by Instagram and disco
made by visco can help you get started
so which one should you use we spend a
little time testing bolt so we've got
some answers let's start with boomerang
the Instagram made app takes short
bursts video like really short one
second short then it speeds it up and
plays it backwards and forwards for four
seconds the video is super clean and you
get a glitchy shaky image technically
it's a video not a gift but the effect
is the same after you've gotten the
perfect one second you can share it out
to Instagram or Facebook if you choose
Instagram you'll be able to slap one of
its beloved filters on top of it
disco is similar but there's one major
difference you can take longer video
bursts giving you more subject options
whereas when you hit capture and
boomerang it seems like times already up
you also swipe over your creations in
Disco to access filters so you won't
have all of the mega granular controls
that visco does so are you looking for
something pretty that fits on Instagram
or something versatile you can do more
with at the end of the day all boomerang
something if it's going to Instagram
only and those images do seem a tiny bit
cleaner but I'm a fan of disco if I
needed to make a gif that goes elsewhere
you